as you all know the opposition media
network is the leader in exposing the
lies that exist all around us but I
can't do all the exposing by myself here
at this desk that's why I have citizen
journalists who go out into the world
and expose themselves they also cover
stories two of them recently did just
that Josh sharp and Aaron Jackson guys
you went out into the field it is some
pretty dicey territory yeah the dicey
Asst Jordan this past weekend there was
a big lefty march in DC called the March
for racial justice now as we all know
liberals don't believe in anything which
is why they have to be paid to show up
so we decided to go and blow the lid off
these walking jars of hypocrisy ooh
nice metaphor I've been practicing
Medical yeah it shows it really shows we
were ready Jordan and a little scared
but we had to see this nefarious
left-wing operation up close rolling
for the last year Trump has been plowing
our country into greatness yet we're
seeing heated protests from the violent
left so what's behind it a lot of these
people led protests a professional
agitators we know for a fact that they
were paying I'd like to see George Soros
stop funding the organizations anytime
there is violent protests bought and
paid for by the Hillary campaign the
Democrat Party or George Soros that's
right the left pays their protesters
even our president knows the truth
that's why we were disgusted when we saw
Amazon's Washington Post promote the DC
local ambassador's a group that actually
helps organize people for margins the
whole thing stank of Soros could they be
his pawns we went to find out sure we'd
love to hang out in front of Trump Tower
all day but we have a job too
infiltrating the violent left so we
figured out that their headquarters are
located in an art gallery so we're gonna
go there okay Norfolk's art right so
make sure that we can go there
undetected we will be deep undercover as
liberals
[Applause]
hello there she was the mastermind
behind this terrifying training ground
we were in now time to interrogate this
Queen pin of chaos in the adorable beer
garden next door volunteers that help
support marches and other events in
Washington we help March organizers with
logistics permitting basically all of
the different ingredients to make sure
that marches go smoothly and our fun
like we wanted to do a march for gender
identity and climate change because a
lot of hurricanes are boy names or girl
names and we want to get them more
gender fluid names that's you know
hitting a lot of buttons could there be
a lot of money for protestors who wanted
to come out for that one we don't pay
protesters George Soros pays the protest
I don't think anyone pays protestors did
you hear that she said she thinks they
don't get me and so we think twe had a
lead
welcome I'm really glad to see so many
new faces we're always looking for new
volunteers tonight we're working for
ticularly ottoman arts for racial
justice your team leader will give you a
call couple days before the March make
sure you know where to show up what to
wear basic things like that I'm sorry
baseball bats are they provided or is it
dude
baseball bats just for you know for
practice
today this is nonviolent and those of us
who are volunteers all say that we are
not going to be participating in
anything that's vile okay until we do
they were clearly stonewalling us but we
pressed on the next step in their
indoctrination was something called
de-escalation training in what sort of
seemed like an improv game we pretended
to be March organizers standing their
ground against angry counter protesters
we clearly passed as liberals our subtle
and nuanced portrayal had fooled them
all I liked using that tactic that we
learned to gang up on somebody and I
wasn't oppress them they accepted us as
two of their own now it was time for the
most dangerous part of our mission going
to one of their organized marches and
exposing saw roses shady plot
new volunteers for you to check in
citations that you keep with you okay
workers comp now that we were dressed as
figures of authority they would have to
tell us who was paying them I don't need
to be paid to stand up for it the
obvious the what's obviously right what
is inherently right that's ridiculous
people get to come and see others like
minded people who will have nothing but
love in the heart for people who look
different all day they lied to us
claiming they cared about the issues
when we knew they must be there for the
cash
why wouldn't they tell us the truth we
already believed and that's when it hit
us
propped signs musical numbers the damn
improv games these people weren't just
nobodies off the street paid to hold
signs they were actors deep in character
and masters of their craft just like us
there was only one thing left to do
excuse me sir sir are you an actor no
damn that's some good actor scene right
there that's the same actor all of them
off quote single script no sides dial
actor these method actors never broke
clearly they lived every day as
passionate citizens who wanted to
strengthen our democracy through civic
action the performance of a lifetime and
that's coming from two of the best
actors around
[Applause]